tab 20 so that's uh aquatic facilities
strategy so
man if you want to deal with that first
and um
thank you thank you so uh the purpose of
this report
is to provide the council with the um
summary of our findings um following the
delivery of the aquatics
strategy so the the main
points out of this is uh 2.5 million
to be included in the long-term plan in
the 24-25 year
for the potential future development of
the site swimming pool in the northeast
of the district
50 000 in the 29 30 year
to fund uh an options paper for the
expansion of kaiapoi aquatic centre
and 1.6 million over the 10-year
long-term plan period
which will be loan funded for capital
asset renewals
the the strategy the aquatic strategy
findings did
highlight the need for further upgrade
and development work at both kaiapoi
and dudley park aquatic centres we
looked at
the council's current project loading
and the affordability
of the economy the community's economic
situation
and decided that that work should be
pushed out further
beyond the current long-term planned
period to ensure
affordability however the purchase of
the land we've included still included
in there
um the point of that is that
um land is never going to be cheaper to
purchase than it is now
um and that keeps our options open in
the future so
if we do go to buy uh build a new pool
in the northeast we have the land there
and if the decision further on is that
we don't want to build a pool but rather
upgrade the other sites in in some or
other capacity
then we we haven't lost that option
um happy to take questions
thank you i'm just looking at the
recommendation
here is what's in the tab at the front
there's place basically bought for the
original recommendation so
a and b if colleagues were minded would
be includes rather than considers i
think would be
what would be required there anyway
questions
questions of matt yes
um council duty followed by council
ballot thank you matt
um just my um question is the
looking at uh perhaps the purchasing of
a
piece of land for future um and
the mere fact is that you're not really
sure if you'll be for a pool
as well or what but i'm just if it was
for a pool would it be like the oxford
pool where the community
does fundraising to put it together and
um
and utilize it that way is that it's not
a covered pool would it be just an open
pool
is that what you're envisioning the the
strategy didn't highlight what sort of
facility it would would
eventually need to be and the purpose
for that is because there's still work
need to be done to
to actually identify closer to the time
when we're building it
the the demographic may have changed um
may have strayed from what we've
predicted so
at this point we're not going to lock we
didn't want to lock ourselves into one
particular solution which may not
meet the needs of the community but that
is a potential and
that the inclusion of the community
giving them ownership of the of the site
would be
key it would be so beneficial for for
the
eventual solution
councilman um matt totally understand
your report but it's an awful lot of
money
um and that money could go towards
putting a roof on oxford it could go
towards putting a hydro site at dudley
it could go towards a whole lot of
other upgrades that would be quite
beneficial for the community now
why would you not go ahead with
upgrading the facilities we have
given that our level of service for pool
is actually quite high in this district
compared to other districts
that's a great question and there's
there's a a lot of options in there and
so part of the
strategy was looking at specific works
for upgrading those other sites
um currently we've pushed all of that
work out
um and just because we feel it's
um the affordability economically is
is that was our recommendation for the
best solution
um however that is council's decision
how they want
so can you see my account savannah
you've got
you've got a 2.4 million dollar budget
in there for the next 10 years
yeah so um the 2.5 million dollars are
looking for land purchase as matt's
already explained is to keep our options
open in the future and in the future if
the decision was to upgrade
the facilities that we already have then
that's still an option that we could do
in the future i think it's important to
note that if we were looking at
upgrading
um either kaiapoi or dudley at the
moment
and the report refers to kaiapoi with
the need
for more leisure services and the need
for hydrotherapy pool somewhere
um 2.5 million is not going to be enough
to be able to actually add on to those
facilities we're looking at
we're looking at 10 20 million dollar
figures to be able to uh add on to
kaiakoi
potentially build a new or add on to
dudley so they're really really big
figures that we've got in our
infrastructure strategy
at the moment rather than the long-term
plan if we had 2.5 million dollars now
to be able to do upgrades to either of
those facilities uh it wouldn't be
enough to actually
achieve what the um shortfall in our
facilities which has been identified in
this strategy
but it would be able to cover the oxford
pool
with a retractor the the feedback
from in the strategy hasn't identified
the
covering of the oxford pool as a
priority for our district at the moment
the priority is
is on leisure services especially in the
kaiapo area because of the shortfall and
public feedback we've had there and then
also because of the demographics in the
district
um the hydrotherapy pool and the
district as well so it wasn't identified
as part of the strategy and
and their strategy included talking to
key stakeholders in the community around
what it is that they actually wanted to
see so you've also noted in the strategy
that um there or in the report that
there are three or
three other facilities being built for
christchurch and opening fairly soon
um wouldn't that satisfy the need for
leisure activities when people
traditionally travel for a leisure or
destination activity
this is the they're quite far away from
our district so
potentially there is some impact of
travel and we've got to get to see
we've yet to wait to see what that
impact is we don't imagine it will be
that large
and the the strategy the team that were
behind the strategy also
concluded that same aspect they didn't
think that travel would be that large
and so if councillor atkinson ward in
redmond
starts around the 2.5 million to secure
land does this actually
i mean i don't get why you're pushing
for a swimming pool is this actually the
community facility or
they're on top of there's another three
million on top of that
for community facilities so we're
actually talking about five and a half
million
for community facilities in this area is
that is that my understanding
yeah there's a land 1.8 million dollars
for the purchase of land for community
facilities and then the 2.54
purchase of land for aquatics and
while it would be nice to to be able to
look at purchasing one piece of land
that would be able to provide both it
might be quite difficult
um being that when if we approach the
developers
of the ravenswood development and look
to purchase land in that area
they're not going to want us to purchase
a large piece of land in a central
location which is going to be able to
cater for
um everything that we've identified here
because they won't want a large area not
developed within the middle of their
subdivision so there is there is a 1.8
million dollars in a further report for
community facilities yes
so so for community facilities out there
we're talking three
four point four point three million
justin land
uh net excludes uh so it's actually more
that because that excludes the
land purchases for pegasus for a
community for facility and pegasus as
well yeah
great so it's about 5.5 for community
facilities in this area land purchase
just for land that's just for land
purchases
okay all right the other thing is that
um i've
just been reading the strategy um you
know we're talking about
10 minute drive to rangiora and a 10
minute drive to
kayak where um in the city what are the
average drives to swimming pools in
there
would be relatively quite similar
especially with the development of the
three new sites um
smith street and lynnwood hornby i think
it's denton park and
in the metro sports some stadiums so
that it would be relatively similar
council award
um have you any idea what the impact and
the likelihood or unlikelihood of the
whale project coming
on stream if that came on stream that
would the hydra side and all those other
sort of facilities that would
that would potentially um accommodate
all the needs of the whole district
surely but so what are your thoughts
there
at the moment as you know they have a
two-year lease on a site and they're
still doing
their detailed feasibility work to see
whether or not
i'm that to go it is it is a completely
different offering
um but but there are some some things
where water safety training and things
like that could be taught in part of the
um the wild um area now because it is a
big open swimming pool especially the
the surf area specifically is a big open
swimming pool essentially so that has to
be taken into consideration and
that's why we've pushed out some of the
work
to have a look at whether or not that
does actually
come about and what the impact of that
would be as well so we've not put in
here any budget to do kai poi um with
the leisure or
or dudley as well so all we've got in
here at the moment is that land purchase
um and the 50k investigation um on
expansion of kaiapoi but that's not
until the 29 30 year and
we should know well and truly the end
around well um and obviously the the
replacement funding so
it will happen and it will have an
impact we just don't know whether it
will go ahead and have a good impact
would be if it were yet
councillor edmund ah thanks chris
and matt um given the cost of of this
proposal and i'm talking about a third
pool
have you considered working in with the
ministry of education and local schools
and having a combined facility or
sharing theirs
which a cuts down the cost of the
capital
cost and b you wouldn't have ongoing
staffing issues because a lot of school
pools are just self-regulated
with parents and at the end of the day a
lot of these sort of
users are kids who really just want to
swim in a
if they want something more more than
that they can travel to kaiapoi or
angora
so any thoughts or discussions
there wasn't any explored in the in the
strategy
we do do some work currently with with
schools and school pools
um however they are a lot of the times
closing or
struggling to do their maintenance to a
acceptable standard and um and we have
been in touch with with local schools to
support them where we can with
with guidance and stuff like that uh
around maintenance and ongoing operation
however um no we haven't explored that
in the strategy
any further questions so we have a
recommendation
are you going to move
okay is a seconder for that
seconded by councillor duty um
rob could you use shemite please thanks
this is a draft for uh for console
tation and i think it's very important
that we indicate to
our community that we are looking
to our community's future with some
wise investment land has never been
cheaper to obtain and on that basis i
will be supporting strongly
uh the data reports with regard to
community facilities
in the largest growth area in our
district
i've only got a glance back a few years
to when pegasus was
first mentioned and there was
a lot of scoffing at the time and i've
got to say that i was partly
included in that and
and look what we have now and it's still
developing
at pegasus look at the demand that's
already been reflected
in undeveloped sections at ravenswood
and quite frankly fellow councillors you
don't need a crystal ball to know where
this area is
going and in the not too far
distant future for us not to be
considering
that future now is burying our heads in
the sand
and setting a future council up for even
bigger expenditure with regard to
this this type of investment look back
only a short time to the purchase on
a cold stream and there was political
debate with regard to
that land banking and to a degree there
was still debate with regard to
that land banking but what a wise
decision
it was for us to in fact make that
purchase
these the same arguments i've had with
the advisory board
over over the years and i'm fully
supportive
of where the advisory board see we
should be
investing as far as this part of the
district is concerned
now so i hope that you will support
the recommendation thank you council
duty
yes thank you and that this is important
for the future generations to
be able to enjoy it is going to be it is
a fast growing
area and we must look after those that
area out there
with whether it be for aquatics
or whatever but that land banking is
really important
so i'm very that's why i have
agreed with this this particular project
thank you
that's about it
when i look at community facilities i
tend to look holistically
and i completely agree that we need a
community facility
in northwood end because the wooden
community center is completely full and
with the huge subdivision at ravenswood
they need more facilities there they're
going to need a meeting place absolutely
and what form that takes that's good but
that's another
report i wish we'd almost been
considering this all together because
really we should be discussing this as a
wooden pegasus development strategy
which is
out of date um it should have been done
as a strategic
overall plan but i don't see the need
for a new pool
in our district i did some research in
similar size districts
as they are now and what they're
providing so when only has one large
facility in its district
the other one's only outdoor pools in
smaller areas
tasman only has one large pool um
one and the rest are all outdoors and
only supervised in the summer
timaru only has one large facility and
there's three smaller ones
which are all outdoor summer only pools
so with us having two indoor facilities
we're actually really really over
we're oversubscribed for a district of
our size and pools eat money
we've seen that the budgets are huge um
and there's not you're not able to get a
return on that
now i i respect the idea of land banking
and i respect the idea of putting that
in but as soon as you put something in a
draft budget
it signals an intent to the community
and i think that's going to give the
wrong message
that we're ever going to be able to
afford another pool
on um and on top of the pools we've
already got
i mean mr brown's already mentioned it
may cost 10 million to upgrade the pools
we've got now
which are sorely needed dudley is
bursting at the seams the leisure
facilities there
are always busy um kaiapoi is lacking
in leisure facilities completely so it's
it's no longer
serving the purpose that's needed for
our aging population
and our young people so looking at this
list i
i believe waimakariri is well served for
pools it's
well served for pills for the next 20
years and i don't believe a standalone
facility is the right strategy
um you know you that money could be used
in so many other ways
to actually upgrade community facilities
like our library
that aren't fit for purpose that need
upgrading so
i think this is the wrong strategy to
have another stand-alone pool within 10
minutes of two others
i don't want to send their intent to the
community i agree with the rest of the
report although i'd like to see kaiapoi
and ring era pools
investigated for upgrades um rather than
just kai poi in the report
but i won't be voting for that line item
and i'll be asking the mayor to please
take that one separately
okay uh council reconcilment mr
and that is that in b
after the word development of we remove
swimming pool and put community
facilities
includes the uh 2.5 on your
paper oh i'm sorry it's different oh is
it different
i'll think about can you just just give
yourself a minute okay and go to the
um which one are we getting yeah yeah
if you go to the front of the order of
paper and the summary agenda
which is pain right so it's page 12
of tears it's going to bring around but
so if everyone just goes to page 12
oh right okay because that's that's what
we're considering now
i'll just give you a minute to think
about that
so it's so big that's a
yeah removes swimming pool and puts
community facilities
what would you like to would you like to
ask a question
the second the first hold on so seconded
by
uh council thank you do you have a
question
well well it is scheduled to
but i've got an amendment on the table
so um
so council right can send to speak to
that please
thank you look that's a very pertinent
question from from
uh from council williams because that's
what i'm actually proposing that this is
looked at holistically
i have sympathies with the uh with the
argument put forward by
council council of any um i have
swimming pools i mean if if you live in
belfast
you travel to papua new guinea um it's
you know that's that's how it is your
argument about uh
we're well served for pools and with
some extension we could be even
better served is is a very clear one
that i think needs debate around here i
have no
question about the the growth and all of
those things that the community
facilities are needed
uh around there i'm not questioning that
argument at
all you have three almost
separated communities in this area and
we need to
talk about that particular issue
on its on its own for a start and where
these go we have a community centre
which already exists in wood end which
is full
we have a community centre which is
leased by the council
in pegasus for the pegasus people
because they rightly came to the
argument say we have a community already
and it is growing that's where we want
it i have no doubt that the ravens
people
ravenswood people will be here in the
next year as they grow and exist in that
area
will come to us and say no no no we want
it here so we are going to have three
distinct communities
fighting for these community facilities
and i mean that
nicely i don't mean fighting as in you
know arguing and things they will want
them
in their area and rightly so but the
proof needs to be
in the pudding and where we put these
and i don't believe we are
at that point yes do yet do we need
facilities
yes i've got no problem with that that's
that's fine but it needs to be looked at
collectively and tying this to a
swimming pool
in my view is the wrong thing to do land
banking i
i take no objection of objection to
because if we decided
that which i don't think would happen
but if we decided that we didn't want
some community facilities the land
will only gain value and you could
recognize your
your money back again so it's it's it's
a very sensible
and uh thing to do and my and my viewers
hold on to that
but actually targeting it with i don't
believe
um an actual conclusion of what we need
yet
is the right thing to do but i do want
to include the
the money within that so i hope you will
uh support the amendment
it doesn't mean that it won't be a
swimming pool
it just means we need to look at a
holistic view of where we're eating
um so can i just just clarify what the
reading says just
inclusion of 2.5 million in the long
term plan for land purchase and 24
25 and take out the rest of the weeding
is that right
for community facilities in the
northeast
is
um i don't think we've reached a point
without our
whole strategy of the the the trio of
pegasus
ravenswood and and woody and where how
they're going to integrate
and and there is this distinct risk that
as neville has said that we'll get three
people
three three entities wanting wanting
a a facility each and and
i i don't think we could go ahead at the
moment with with their pool
plan without without resolving that and
resolving
where it's going to go and where and
whether it's going to be integrated
as part of a wider and that's why that
wording is good
because it's not it's not negating it
it's just leaving the options wide open
so and i sympathize with robbie's
comments about land banking
it's always i'm okay with land banking
because you can always sell it again
so yeah so science asked question of
counselor
so when it comes to the future report
further report around you indicating
that you consider that in addition
this 2.5 would be in addition to right
okay thank you further speakers
council brian
[Music]
oh mike please think so i don't have a
an issue with the
the wording change um as i say it's
land banking and i just point out that
it's 24 25
and someone mentioned with regard to
strategies i'd sincerely like to think
that some strategizing is going to be
taking place
before we get to 24 25 i would be very
surprised
if that was was not the case
and i would like to think that
colleagues
do not see this as just the only
investment in community facilities
as mentioned we do have other items on
the agenda and as a
signal when i spoke and the first
instance i fully intend to support
that investment uh as as well as along
with this
but i don't have a problem with the
because you know certainly as long as
i'm around i'll remember
this conversation and
mr speakers uh council obama do you want
to speak as well
do council are you indicating
yes but for that the wording to be
changed as well
oh well it's an amendment now so um so
council barnet yes this this is really
really similar to debate we had last
time about community facility library
and we decided to take the word library
out to leave it more open so that we can
actually develop a plan going forward
for the long term
so i'm actually quite sympathetic
because i'm i did worry the 1.8 wasn't
going to be enough
so actually adding the 2.5 gives us some
leeway
to make some informed choices around
budget
and we may not need all that but that
would be great if we didn't need it
that's great but it's available in the
in the long term plan
just a note on the william pegasus
development strategy part of the reason
it hasn't been
redone is because of the district point
of view we just have not had the staff
and the resources to be able to review
um the district development and that
needs to be done
now that the district plan work is out
of the way or starting to
get to a point of a conclusion and that
will be the next step
and we desperately need to acknowledge
the importance and the growth in the
audience pegasus area
we need to acknowledge the connectivity
between them we need to acknowledge
the need for community facilities in
their area
so i do think that actually putting this
budget in is a signal to that community
and that we are looking at them that we
do care that we do really want them to
be able to have
the same sort of facilities that are
seen in the other major towns in our
district
so i'm fully in support of the amendment
mr palmer just just to observe and
without preempting what might be decided
later
when you get to the next community
facility provision for 1.8 million
uh i just note that that's in year 2122
and this is 2425. i
in just probably highlight that it is
likely that
um if you were if we were looking to try
and co-locate
then we'd probably try and um secure
that in one go so it may
see a request for this 2425 budget
to come forward if those negotiations
land positively in that space in 2122 so
i just wanted to
signal that while it's sitting in 24 25
at the moment
the likelihood is if it were
in a single location that it probably
would probably get a better deal if we
were trying to buy a bigger block
in terms of value for money than two
separate purchases
so i just just played do you wish to
speak or you've got a question
jim based on what you've just said there
and jeff is probably back there
furiously working numbers um what what
does that do
bringing a significant sum like that
forward
with the 1.8 being
proposed for the 21-22 year
and this pool budget being for
24.25 um if we brought that forward what
does that do with our
to our rates numbers and whatnot that
you just
um probably push again
the right of the rate of fit and jeff
can kick me in the pants
uh quickly if he uh wishes the rate of
yeah so what it all the the effect is
you bring you bring two and a half
million dollars worth of debt uh
forward so that raises debt earlier than
has otherwise signaled
so that's one effect the the
funding cost on two and a half million
is probably not that significant in
the current interest rate environment um
probably somewhere
somewhere in the order of
a hundred up to a hundred thousand
dollars
is cost that had come forward earlier so
you know
again it depends on what wouldn't be
decided in this round but in the future
ltp or annual plan there's probably some
re-spreading of
rate impact 100 000 dollars
in terms of a percentage of rate is
about
point one to point two somewhere in
there just depending
question there's a question but it's to
do
was just reminding me that there's a
small element of growth in that
um we'll be getting the dc's whether
it's in year 24 25 or 21 22 so
we will still get the dc's as and when
they fall
due if they if there's an assessed
growth component to this investment
and why aren't people going oh don't
know
um and look i wouldn't
in the broad scheme of things like many
of the things that we talk
about um that doesn't become
particularly material if there's no
if there is no dc's where in in any
particular year that you gave the
increase to it's a 0.1
of a percent rate
just by um and and that rate increase
would have occurred
it's just that it's occur it would occur
a couple of years earlier than
what is currently signaled so
question well just the intent of the um
of the amendment is in in what jim has
explained is one scenario but it wasn't
my intent
to be going out and buying five and a
half million dollars worth of land it
may be that we still have two separate
parcels we might have three we might
have whatever is required
what i'm trying to do is get the get
this so that it doesn't it's not tagged
to anything that the community
facilities
can add up to that amount of land is
what i'm saying that's
that's my intent um so you was you did
right that could be a scenario that
comes out of it but i just want to make
that clear that it's not
saying let's go and buy five and a half
million dollars of a panic that's not
what i'm saying
okay accounts of two questions
can you use your microphone please it's
hard to reach
um so this amendment
that effectively means that the the
budget we've got in front of us stays
exactly the same is that correct
correct thank you any further speakers
oh sorry council redmond
thank you mr mayor i'm sympathetic to
the propositions put forward by
councilman barnett and
i think councillor atkinson except i'm
just wondering by
changing the wording um if it looks like
a pool it's still going to be a pool
whether it's called a community facility
or a pool
so we're just playing with words or is
there something substantive here
i mean what other community facilities
could we expect to find in the aquatics
strategy it's not a community centre i
don't think the pools
uh deal with those so i'm just wondering
is there any substance to
changing some words i mean the real
issue is do we need another pool
in that area are there other
alternatives to a pool
so i'd like some clarification from
the mover of the motion what exactly he
means by
community facilities is it a poll
or what else is it um before voting on
the amendment
i'll give you a normally but i will give
you a right of reply and you can respond
to that at that time
unless you want to respond specifically
i'm pretty sure to explain myself i'm
talking about
the community facilities as as total i'm
not
talking about particularly a pool if we
need five and a half there million
dollars five
thousand that'd be nice um
in which to create community facilities
of which they could be anything
i'm not satisfied that we have
uh that we have the information in front
of us that that is required i mean
you've heard the questioning from people
already around do we need a pool here we
haven't had that debate
that is here um we wanted to go out for
consultation we think about community
facilities
as a whole and this just so happens that
that's part of it
and we need to know that and i i don't
believe we have that information
we have one report that's all
yeah i couldn't support this amendment
because i think
we would need to for community
facilities wait to the next one
and see the value we put on what we need
then
rather than being targeted in a
particular
equity um environment um
report so i think we need to wait till
we get to the community facilities one
and um
somewhere out there maybe we need to
increase that amount
then for land um but this is not the
right way of doing it
in this scenario because it still points
to the aqua
situation and we don't know we haven't
um
debated it properly
i don't speak to i feel the same way as
councillor williams actually
um and look i just have to signal on for
the record i
i'm not persuaded that i think we need
to be investing in a
another pool at the present time i would
rather the investment goes into our
current facilities
and future proof so it's my priority is
actually the
ones that we've had and i'm going to
speak to future reports coming but
because it's been signaled i would like
to see a set aside land
uh and uh look to the investment
in in in the not too distant future and
pegasus particularly of a community
facility
i think we've identified that and that
is certainly the priority i've heard
from our
uh community and set aside the land and
ravenswood
for future options i'm not persuaded on
a facility for a pool at the present
time
there's such short distances and i
remember how divisive it was years ago
when we were trying to
even do dudley at the time now we have
with both dudley and with um
kaibwe aquatic center two very good
facilities
uh our youth council i'm sure will be
submitting wanting
a hydra slide if not up dudley also it
um they probably would like it at oxford
as well
um but this shows that our young people
are
thinking of those things and and the
other sort of things you know qe2 has
got a high demand because it's got a
and well used because it's got that um
hydro slide
aspect from what i'm advised so on the
face of it i'm not going to support the
amendment um yeah it's getting a bit
messy i think
the way this has has been amended it's
no reflection on
on what's been intended here but um
if if our discussion is about future
land let's deal with that when we come
to talking about
um future land purchase and have that
all as one
consideration and we can look at the
timing of that and that's coming up in
the future report so i i'd rather
have that conversation then and then we
resolve what we're going to do at that
point but
this this particular point i'm no i'm
not going to support you
okay so further speakers you'll get a
reply in the next
after it comes
of emotion can you exercise your right
to reply at this time but you don't give
further
would you like to exercise you is there
any further speakers before we come to
that
would you like to exercise your vote
well i think i think it would pay
because
potentially the amendment's going to to
fail
which will mean we go back to
substantive and gathering by the
comments
i don't think the substantive will go
through either
so that will mean that there is no 2.5
million provision
in the long term plan for whether it be
a community facility or will it be for a
potential swimming pool
in the northeast of the district and on
that premise it'll
judging by the comments there's some
other report that's going to be i
thought all the reports were here
for consideration as part of our draft
long-term plan
now and you know i was heavily involved
in dudley the lead up took
years to get w over the line
we had a deputy mayor
disclaiming it as a neighbourhood pool
vigorously opposed to it as were
at various points the majority of
councillors which was why i was on the
books and off the books and on the books
and off the books
you know we're not talking about a
facility being
built in the near future here we're
talking about land banking
for the possibility of that facility
and there's an awful lot of water to go
under that particular
bridge before a facility could be
built but with dudley we owned the land
with kaipoi we owned the land we weren't
having to purchase
with oxford we owned the land we weren't
having to purchase land
all i'm asking is that this council have
the foresight
to purchase the land under whatever guys
so that's why it's indicated i don't
have a problem with the amendment
we'll have that discussion later but for
heaven's sake
invest in the land invest in your
community now
for their and our future
that's all i'm asking for in this and
it's all i'll be asking for
later so i hope mr mira this
may have persuaded you to at least
support the amendment
because and it's a draft for
consultation we can have this discussion
again later
um yeah but i would like this to get
over the line
for our community to have an opportunity
to consult on it
thank you
so did you have a question councilwood
would it be possible to reconsider the
1.8 million in the light of this
that's going to come up in the future
report so that's in
the future report is in tab um tab 17
for 4.15 which talks about
pegasus ravenswood community facilities
but well that's just just i'm just
trying to resolve a situation where
we well anyway so we have an amendment
i'm going to put the amendment
all those in favor please say aye
contrary
no division
yep so you want to clarify what it's
yes so the amendment is uh
tia could you read that back please
okay okay
everyone clear on that so the chief
executive pool and the tech division
[Music]
williams council
i'm looking at my list rather than
looking at the people sorry
so sorry council award
the amendment's lost so we come back to
the original recommendation
so it's been moved and seconded
and you've exercised your right reply
[Music]
given that i now suspect that i won't
pass
do you intend to take yes that's
separate
yes
so with that i'll is there any further
speakers
to the original motion i know you've
exercised your writing reply
i haven't already spoken to it if you
wish to speak
it was suggested that
this amount is may get lost or pass
but there is no reason that 1.8
can't be added to if we we think we do
need a
better facility there coming up later in
the meeting so
this is just on the aqua side so
okay well anyway we is there any further
speakers that haven't already spoken
wish too
all right so i'll put the um the motion
um and i'm going to take them separately
so firstly
i'll put a all those in favor please say
aye
contrary
division
so i carrick yes so um sandra
it's only if you go back to the original
um
sorry you went in here and that was so
you go to the summary agenda
and it's page
11 or 12 i think it is 12 12.
and it changes the words
from considers to both an a and b
to includes so what what
we originally what you're looking at in
your report was effectively a report
that went to council or
cnr back um the end of last year
have you caught up with it
page 12
okay
all right all right division
[Music]
williams
black
so i assume that everyone's happy with
the rest being considered as one
okay so now put b through to
h i'll put that all those in favor
please say i
contrary and declare that carried right
i think we're now in um
your papers so matt is there anything
you'd like to highlight in there for us
sorry everyone that's pages
432 well effectively 433 on
so obviously as a result of that vote
the the
in my key issues it mentioned the 2.5
million so we won't be
touching on that again um but um the
main
actually later on yeah i'll hang around
though
yeah um i shall um so the the key issues
are mainly as per the report
um the uh except for the fees and
charges
um so i'd just like to talk quickly to
that um
there has as you're awake over it has
had a huge impact on our business
um and there's still potential with
strains of
south african variants and and um
and uh british variants as well there's
there's unknown
what that impact is going to continue to
be on our business um we have
proposed uh a two percent increase
across
all charges um in line with our policy
of now
doing small but incremental increases to
lessen the impact on the community for
some of the smaller fees that's
that's worked out as a 1.5 to between
1.5 to 3
increase just because they're quite
small amounts
um and the other
couple of items was that the adult fee
increase
in the parent and preschooler fee
increase those both came out of
recommendations from the aquatic
strategy so that's on
page 437 as my fees and charges um
so uh yeah happy to take oh the other
item sorry was the training budgets i
had a question
about the training budgets um the which
is which fallen both dudley kaiapoi
and oxford pools there was
during covert our training budgets
because we weren't training the staff we
were all at home
uh training budgets across council were
halved
essentially and this is actually just
putting them back where they were
it does appear to be doubling them
however it's just putting them back
where they were
it does look significant however it's
important to note that these training
budgets are for safety sensitive
training that is required for the
ongoing operation of the pools if we
were to cut this we would need to
seriously look
at the health and safety risk of
operating product facilities so
happy to take questions thanks matt
any questions of matt council williams
use your mic please counseling thanks
sorry
what's the expectancy life of some of
this equipment because some of it
doesn't
appear to be a you know that old you
know you know two and a half million
dollars
replacement on is it is it a a
maintenance problem or
just a failure of equipment or is it
we haven't put the right equipment in or
so the the the budget over the long term
plan period
um was around 600 667
000 for capital replacements we
have performed a project with the helper
assistance of the green space um asset
officer um uh and to
where we went through looked at all the
items in the plant to actually identify
whether we had the correct life spans
some of those items the lifespan was put
at
you know 30 years for a plant that a
piece of equipment that only lasts about
five
so pulling that all back forward um has
has created this
need for an increase it is also
important to note that
um that facilities like kaiapoi was
built back in the 90s and some of the
plant has been
nursed since then so there are a lot of
items that are ongoing and
of an advanced stage so
my question was um some of the life
expectancies
of this equipment is obviously not
lasting as long as
you said summer it's been for 30 years
95 years
is there a warranty or who designed all
that equipment originally
if we expect the life expectancy of 30
years and we're only getting five years
you know i'm sort of yes i i think it's
actually the planning that we've done
which has been the problem not the life
expectancy of the
gear that we've got i mean it's similar
to community facilities
our planning previously was to buy a
large piece of kit
and then look at its life expectancy as
a whole piece of kit and so that's 30
years so we'll depreciate that over that
30 years
we've found out as you'll know over the
last
three to six years that we keep having
to come back to council and so
the piece of kit's generally okay but
there's a component part of it which is
broken and that component part
was never separated to make sure that we
had the money to replace that
while the bigger piece of kit store
remains the same so we've gone into a
lot more detail to say look
you might have a big boiler system but a
part of that is going to need to be
replaced every five years to make sure
that the expensive part actually
continues to
to operate and so we've um keith down at
um
kaiapoy has done a huge project working
with the suppliers and working with the
maintenance
crews to break it down into component
parts and then actually have life spans
on each of those parts so that we can
actively maintain and replace um
properly
you'll note that we have come back to
council seeking ongoing money
which equates to about what we're asking
for here so the options are to
continue to come back to council every
year and ask for money to upgrade
these component parts of the larger
items or to
have a better forward plan a more
complex ford plan which actually has the
money identified now
so it's not worthwhile upgrading to
better quality
some some of some of some of the items
in here do reach their life expectancy
within that 10 years and
then we have to look at upgrading them
and and we've identified the right
amount of money to upgrade them with
good quality
kit further questions
about yes and thanks matt for all the
responses to questions i just want to
tease one out a little bit more
and that is the rather large increase to
the parent and preschool of fee
from 3.60 to 4.50
is there a possibility or how much
impact would it have on the budget
to smooth that out a little bit more and
make the jump not quite so large like 25
it's quite a large jump in one year
absolutely smoothing that is potentially
a solution
um these were the the pricing review
was uh page 571 if you want to look it
up of the um
of the aquatic facilities strategy they
looked at
the relativity of our prices across i
think it was uh
22 similar pools nationally and they
found that the adult price was about 95
of the average price and our parent
employee school of price was about 80
so that's where the the increase came
from um absolutely we can smooth that
over
over a couple of years potentially
further questions
okay um the status quo meant
is has already been agreed by the
council um
to start with unless anyone has an
amendment apart from what we've just
previously discussed
but um just in general thanks to you and
your team for what you do
um you run a really good um
at our facilities really well and i can
constantly write great feedback about
that so thank you for what you and the
team do
and and and as we previously said over
the covered period you were redeployed
in supermarkets and all sorts of things
so
a truly versatile team so um
no but uh and thanks very much we and if
you could pass that on to your team on
our behalf that would be great
all right okay
so the next on the chris are we
dealing with community development now i
know tess is not here
are you happy to just
okay thanks man
richie do you want well it could be
finished before she arrives potentially
should we just do you want to crack on
yeah i think so because we're
there's no tabbed items so let's just
get into it
if you're happy to cover that for tessa
great
white pages 4417
um
mommy
okay any questions
um with that happy to take any general
comments anyone wants to make
apart from i think tessa knows we talked
to the
many times uh our thoughts on on what
she her and her team do which is
and her leadership in particular really
outstanding so
um particularly with covert 19 and other
matters that we that she's
constantly involved with so thank you if
you pass it on to tessa
um for us that would be great chris all
right so
right all good green space
press ground
page four 455.
now that you've said there
just want to just draw attention to the
sartorial elegance of your other
teammates
hey
yup should we
and deal with the we'll deal with the
reports first yes
so could you use your mic chris please
thanks just for
tears benefiting the recording system
thank you
just bearing in mind i should remind we
are being recorded and i think
it's not being live streamed at the
moment is there but it will be uploaded
yeah
okay chris
uh yes i was just referring to the pages
uh so the first report that we'll talk
to is uh
tab 15 on the computer page 317
item 4.13 which is the sports facilities
plan so if everyone's there then i'll
hand over to
the ground so the recommendation chris
is just for everyone else's benefit if
you go to
tab two um in the year which must be
about
pages 12 or 13 i dimension um
let's find them here just so everyone
knows what the recommendation is
um
page nine of your
of the summary agenda page
thank you
all right grant thank you good afternoon
just
um yeah so myself and ryan will be here
today from
uh green space so i'll take the report
mostly as
uh red i guess a couple of things that
we wanted to point out with the sports
facilities plan this is an update to
the last iteration that we had before
the previous ltp
we got rsl consultants to go out
and update the information and the data
that was within that so that we could
have a look at what our capital program
might look like going forward in terms
of what we would propose through the ltp
the good news is is that many of the
things that
we'd identified in that previous
strategy have actually been
successfully completed so we've put
money into the
kaiapoi high school indoor court area
the lights at dudley park although they
were interrupted heavily by covert last
year and now they're fully functional
and bookable for this season
and we've also increased some of our
drainage capacity
around the district as well and there's
some indoor courts
being built within the district as well
at the main power stadium
so look probably the key thing is that
we're looking at is future capital
program
which is what we're asking you to
consider primarily today for the ltp
you'll note that we've got some
reductions in the early years
however we do have a slight increase
heading out into further years which are
looking at the artificial turf
replacements
some of the costs that we've got around
those we are collecting back through
some of the fees and charges that we are
putting out to some of the
clubs it's fair to say that not all of
the clubs have got the same
capacity and capability to continue to
pay that and we are working with them
and also their regional sporting body
and sport canterbury as well
because that's not a situation that we
would like to see continue
so we're looking at trying to build some
capacity within their executive team as
well as their staff
to actually look at how we can turn that
around and and actually bring some of
that money back in because they were
depreciated
with that in mind um that's mostly
pointing out to kendall park astroturf
apart from that we've got some drainage
that we would like to improve across the
district as well as just building some
of the capabilities within our sporting
groups as well so
look i'm happy to take questions on any
of these
points thanks grant questions
let's see so there's a recommendation
on the order paper at four point one
five
some are prepared to move moved by
council brian's signify
and the report's very self-explanatory
thank you very much for
putting it together for us okay
thank you so 4.13 i did say point one
five so apologies it was four point one
three
um distance second thing i agree um
thanks grant
uh and it's including things that we
need to have included there so
absolutely in full support of that any
further contributions
you can exercise the right reply if
you'd like to count surprises
okay i'll put that all those in favor
eye
contra to clear that carry okay so
um next is 4.14
so that's um
4.14 is tab um
16. but also just bear in mind to refer
to your
summary as well for what the
recommendations are
okay so grant again i'll take the report
as read
what we're really looking at here
chris brown mentioned this in the
previous report with the aquatic
strategy
there are things within our community
facilities that we have started to delve
into the
the asset planning with i guess on a a
much broader basis
ryan who deals with our asset management
plan
has been looking at okay what do these
renewal programs actually look like
how we're going to ensure that we've got
all of the components listed
um it would be fair to say that with the
cast community centre project that we
did recently we actually learned quite a
lot of
things around how we need to look at our
asset management
how we need to structure our budgets and
how we need to actually look at these
things because we came across a number
of issues there with fire compliance
general compliance and also just some of
the materials that were there that we
needed to change
and look there's individual sports as
well whose governing body
or organizations are actually changing
the way that they're allowed to operate
and putting new safety measures in place
as well so that's kind of leading us to
need to respond that when we actually go
and do some work
for example if we were going to go and
renew some of the
materials and some of the components at
low burn pavilion
there would be a number of compliance
things that we would need there so we
need to produce a holistic
building consent in order to do that and
that's actually going to have listed all
of the components that we're looking at
replacing renewing
how our electrical circuits are working
how our fire compliance is working
all of those sorts of things so that
actually the buildings are up to
standard as to what they were so
we can't just go in and reduce or kind
of renew
curtains and put some new jib up what we
actually need to do is come up with some
ballistic plans around how our
facilities are going to perform
the kinds of things that we need to do
and look this budget
is being drawn down from money that
we're already depreciating
so the money is sitting there it's just
that we haven't necessarily drawn it
down what we're proposing to you now
is that we're actually going to start to
draw this down and do the projects the
way that we did cast
although a lot more coordinated i can
assure you councillor barnett
in terms of how we're actually
approaching that from start to finish so
that we can actually look at the end to
end of
how all of our facilities look um it
would be fair to say that with hvac
systems and with some of those
electrical things we're kind of looking
at them now as components and as their
own assets
they will be on a very different regime
to the ceilings
and the floors and some of those other
things that we have within the buildings
as well
so we won't necessarily just be looking
at an entire building
in the future once we get through this
initial 10-year work program it'll be a
case of okay all of these assets we know
that they're on a five or a six-year
replacement cycle so
that'll be a lot more natural we're
going to be building capacity with our
contractors and also with the people who
know how to manage these things
that will help to avoid some of the
issues that we've had with this the hvac
in this building in particular
so that we're actually building the
capability of the people who are who are
servicing our contracts as well so
there's a whole end-to-end there that
are actually it's going to allow us to
be a lot more efficient in our delivery
and it's going to ensure that our key
levels of service around the offerings
of the buildings being open and not
closed
are going to be maximized as well
so look i'm happy to take questions on
that report
thank you questions of grant council
grant when a building sits on a
footprint it includes the surrounding
area
how are you going to tie in the
facilities budget with
the external budget which are done
managed in two different
by two different areas of staff and have
you have you got a plan
for making sure that you're not
upgrading a building but then leaving
the carpet terrible for example
yes and again i'd reference back to some
of the projects we've done recently
where you know that
holistically wasn't planned so that's
the whole point of this is that what
we're doing
is looking at their holistic approach
the reality is
we are community in green space so we
look after community facilities as well
as green space most of those assets tie
together
um where there's a library or an
aquatics facility myself and paula or
myself and
matt or be it ryan um we actually work
quite closely together to have a look at
it because
ultimately we're all answerable to chris
who's all answerable to you
um so from our perspective it's a
community and recreation approach
that's what these assets and facilities
are there for but
yes we have noted the learning from that
so it will be a
i guess a different approach to how we
do all of the assets both internally and
externally
i guess what i'm asking is have you got
enough budget in the complementary
area of the externals to match this
new budget for the buildings
we have different replacement budgets
for hard surfaces
so for car parks we have a completely
different replacement budget and then we
also have
different replacement budgets for our
soft
landscaping features around the outside
as well
we also have a budget called the
non-specific reserve enhancement budget
and that's the budget that we tie into
to
to allow us to be able to do holistic
developments of um
community green space um and community
facility activities so
if we're looking at a building and i'll
use logan because because grants use
logan
and i believe in the first maybe in year
two or three of
the replacements here logan does have
around 450 or something like that
to be spent on load burn to bring it up
to compliance level at the same time
we'll have to have a look at the car
park
we'll have to have a look at the
landscaping around and we'll have to
have a look at all of those budgets
at the moment some of those budgets are
smoothed out over a period of time
so that we can build up money to be able
to pay um if we get to a situation where
um because of that smoothing we have to
come back to council and say look we
would like to be able to pinch some from
next year to be able to complete this
project holistically then we'll do that
at the time
i just have a question around it's on
page 381 which is cast community center
and there are a number of items listed
there that uh
to be done within years one to three
exactly when
will that be complete this sorry it's in
the white pages
um not white pages on the um tab in the
main report
page 381 or our page 381
so just following the upgrade these are
the remaining items to be
completed excluding the car park and
exterior
and sorry car parking issues so when
will that be
when will that be undertaken that's
included in there
so we have a budget currently listed as
roads and car parking within the green
space budget it's expected that cust
would either fall into part of that so
that's every two years starting in year
two of the next ltp
um or we have identified this in year 11
as a bespoke
project which is obviously sitting
outside of the current ltp
so these items are listed here things
that
we completed as part of the current
upgrade which
probably should have if we had adequate
budget so when will they be
undertaken uh so with that these are
carpet replacement and
those things it looks pretty shabby in
there
that was within the first they would be
within the first three years those ones
okay so it could be year one yep
and ultimately if there's a desire by
the council for us to
uh look particularly at putting a
project as first cab off the rank then
we'll happily do that thank you
for the questions that's redmond
ah thank you on page 384
and diligent um septum domain pavilion
similar question to the mayors
um there's a lot of refurbishment
proposed for that pavilion but that
pavilion
may or may not be remaining so we
wouldn't really want to go spend
money on it in the short term
yeah yeah so that's not in the short
term that one and we've still got to go
through some public consultation with
theft and domain move
with the community hall moving to the
domain so but
given that it's a current asset we've
still got to list it here knowing that
it
might not be that in the future
i mean it is listed but it seems to me
you've got a budget for exterior
painting toilet replacement
led lighting changing room refurbishment
i realized nothing's set in stone yet
but there is a signal that
things may be changing so would we
wanted that spending money on this
for something so in the program that's
identified in year four to six
so we wouldn't be looking to do any of
that work until year four to six and
between now and year four to six we'll
know a whole lot more and we can
revise that budget if the building needs
to be significantly modified but we're
treating this budget as
as if the domain is going to that
building is going to remain there and
not be touched until we know more
could you help me whereabouts is that in
the papers or
uh so this is part of the um replacement
budget which we're discussing um under
4.14 so
it's identified as the 150 in year one
and then 300 every year moving out to um
through through eight seven and then 350
for the last three years so like i said
it's smoothed out over those 10 years
okay any other questions councilwoman
you were you still answering chris saw
it
[Music]
so hold on guess about it just wait yes
i'm sorry
memories
okay thank you
uh cassava so just going back to
something you just said which related to
my first question
you're saying that the cass community
center works are pretty much programmed
in the early part of
for the building but that the full
court's been pushed out to year 11
why would you do the inside and not the
front of the building at the same time
so we also have a roads and car parks
budget where we could bring that into
year two
of the current ltp so the year 11 is a
placeholder depending on what happens
with that because it's a proposed new
budget
remember of course i i think there might
be some confusion between
and the identifier
between the request to look at a new car
park at cust
and which is the year 11 i believe
you're talking about
which is looking at the land at the back
for a new car park and
the by the tennis court that's right and
the redo
of the current car park at the front so
they're
two separate projects so i'm just
confused about the year 11
where it's been pushed to year 11. it's
only been out of the current long-term
plan when that's still a current project
so the tennis court car park um
is in year 11 at the moment and could be
brought forward into an earlier year but
that's not a renewal work
that was a new work which has been
identified
and that's currently sitting in year 11
of the budget
so so the renewal of the
current car park in the front part of
the building where is that where will
that form part of
where is it on the budget
i believe i think that's i can comment
on this one
um so the roads and car park upgrade is
currently out for tinder at the moment
forecast forecast um that's relating to
the funding we receive from the
government
as part of the show already or the
stimulus package right
um so the car park upgrade and that is
currently timber
at the moment but a new car park for
tennis
is currently not sitting in the budget
okay all right next to tennis any
further questions council redmond
uh just to clarify my previous question
chris
on page 492 we've got the sefton domain
pavilion
and those various maintenance issues and
so on um i can't tell from looking at
that
that you're not proposing to do any of
this work until year four
so so that's the way that the budgets
are actually um
identified in our budget sheets so in
those within the
sift and budget specifically that's an
operational budget not a capital or
capital renewals budget so all the items
in
the sefton line will be operational
items um
the capital that we have for renewals at
the moment
is on that page 489
and we have a program which sits behind
those
numbers which are in there so all of the
buildings have their own operational
codes
separated within the budget but when it
comes to capital and
capital renewals those are identified in
a separate space not as individual
building lines
that's why you don't see the renewal for
each building as a program inside each
of those operational budgets
any further questions
so we have a recommendation so just to
be
clear that's within the um
order paper itself 4.14
some are prepared to move moved
councillor becky
uh seconded by council awards sorry
screaming by
councilling
yeah just to say i'm actually delighted
to see that this budget has gone in and
we have noticed obviously since after
the earthquake there was a huge amount
of work in that area and green space and
buildings and a lot of things got missed
and and
that's been acknowledged and so now
we're actually getting into a point
where we can
come back and review all of our
facilities and make sure that they're
being adequately serviced and that
actually prolongs the life of the essay
which is really good for the community
and
for the budget um i am a bit concerned
sometimes however though that we get
projects
which make a building so much better it
gets so much more use but then we don't
have enough car parking
so we've got i really do think that
these sort of development plans need to
go hand in hand i know they're in
different budgets
i know they're in different staff units
but they have to go hand in hand to make
a realistic
use of the building and the use of the
project so i'm a bit concerned that some
of the projects i see
focus on one or the other and it's
and those staff aren't always
coordinating together so i really look
to you grant
to make sure that happens in the future
all right i agree with those comments
and in particular case and pointers cast
community centre
we got a really good amount of work in
that building and then we had to stop
completing the remainder which was would
have been replacing the carpet and the
vinyl the rest of it looks fantastic now
um
and it's nicely painted but just the
flooring looks pretty shabby
and of the age that was built in the
1970s thank goodness the color scheme
has changed
uh it's just just a reflection of the
time but it would have been great to
have got those
that completed all at the same time i
realised there was budget constraints
there so my preference you asked for
that before would be that it's completed
in year one
um so that facility is as up to speed as
it can be
our community it is a well used facility
too so
um but i do agree with council barna
it's great that we have
all our facilities listed there and
there is a plan on the condition
in a program so that we don't fall
behind
so thanks team great uh great great to
see this here today
in fear the speakers write reply
i'll put that all those in favor aye
contrary to clear that
carried right
uh we're now on tab 17
which is um 4.15 so
that's the report on pegasus ravenswood
community facilities
um chris when we go to the
uh in grant when we go to the um
summary um summary recommendations don't
probably don't reflect we're similar
before just wording
so probably a a c
and that probably should have includes
um would be my
suggestion there and then d probably is
where we
were talking of before might be an
opportunity to think about what a
realistic sum
should be included there but i don't
want to preempt the discussion here but
there's something that chris you might
and grant might want to think about if
you could just give us some guidance
as to what the wording should be be
helpful as well
thank you um
so this is just picking up on the point
before that was discussed with the
aquatics facilities
uh strategy so um
that's that's quite all right
does joan shout after today
well it's clearly it's
look it's like us all it just turns
itself
on
is it on silent now
right um grant please reca if you could
restart
thank you it's all right i i honestly
didn't get someone to just call you john
um so you just uh
just to look through um through this one
i think we'll get to the wording on d
um i'd just like to frame a little bit
of the report first if uh
if i may um through the chair
uh it's this is kind of looking into
two parts so we currently got a again we
commissioned rsl to go out there and do
a feasibility study for us to
look at the kind of community facility
provision that we will be needing within
the northern reaches of our of our
district
we had previously put placeholders in
between the placeholders being put in
and then pushed out quite far
the pegasus community in particular has
a an existing
community centre that's currently leased
um
the population out there has actually
grown during that period of time from
around about just over 2 000 people
up to i think we've got about 3700 there
now
joan that we silent things on the side
if it's an iphone
just to help you i gotta join a cup of
water
[Laughter]
so if it's on that you know whether we
saw that thing is on the side
it's on the iphone is this an iphone
okay well there we go anyway
sorry carry on grant sorry it's all
right we always plan for these sorts of
things
um yeah so
pegasus uh since then we've leased the
facility as i say
it was around about um just over 2000
people were expecting growth there now
um realistically about two four thousand
potentially just over within pegasus
um there had always been a placeholder
from a previous study done by sue
sutherland around some sort of facility
there
it's become quite evident over the last
probably two years in particular in
with the tenacity of the local residence
group as well
um around how they
passion yeah passion that i don't view
that as a negative
um actually pushing um for this
this project we have been i would say
relatively lucky in the last couple of
years we've had a change of ownership of
who owns the current leased building
um with the change of ownership that
always leaves you in a bit of a
vulnerable position we now have an
established
facility in an established service there
had that gone uh poorly in terms of the
transover of uh
of um owners with templeton group
we might have found ourselves in a
situation where the biggest community
actually had nowhere to
to meet hence why staff and
also the consultants have kind of
identified that it would be really good
to bring the land purchase for that
facility into year one of the ltp and
then we actually look for a three-year
program of actually building and
constructing that as well
the idea being that there's obviously a
service there and that would tie in with
the
rounding up of the lease which templeton
even though it's on the market have
given us some assurances that we would
be able to retain the use of that
there's no getting away from the fact
that we don't control the destiny of
that building that we're currently in
um with a purpose-built facility we do
and that gives the residents association
some a surety um it will also be a
really good addition if it's put in the
areas that we hope it's put in
um to help drive some stimulus within
the local um
i guess you would call it commercial uh
land sector as well and also just around
the lake there too
so looking it's got some really good
positives as a side to that
there's also the tie-in of the youth or
skate facility for pegasus
um that's really reliant on if we can
get a good outcome with the community
facility
it makes sense given what we've looked
at with the matrix for
a youth space that the two of those are
tied together
so it's kind of bringing an optimal
solution in for pegasus
so that's the first part of the report
the second part is one that you've
already had a bit of a debate around
this morning and that is
a wood-end ravenswood
community facility what we know about
that particular area right now is that
there's expected growth
within the district and there's kind of
a mass happening there
there's quite a few factors that are
coming into play for for that particular
area one is obviously the current
discussion around
okay what does the bypass look like how
does that change how old end operates
and how does that actually kind of
affect how people would travel around
that area
we've got huge growth potential there we
could potentially end up with another 10
000 residents which we've
you know is trending and those
assumptions are kind of being proven
correct as we currently go
and the new motorways that nzta have
thus far
funded and put and have changed the
travel times and accessibility into
north canterbury
quite phenomenally what was a 42 minute
drive in tehringyora is now potentially
around about a 27.
my google app tells me i don't know how
it knows but it knows more about me than
i do
but it tells me every morning that my
average journey into the
service center here from the center of
christchurch is now 27 minutes
and so that's based on an average that's
making our district really really
accessible so it's going to become
a much more vibrant place in terms of
well not vibrant but a much more viable
place in terms of people moving out here
which is what we all know
so that in itself is going to change the
dynamic of that particular area so we're
relatively confident in the growth that
we're going to get there
which also means that doing some of the
land banking around the community
facility approach
is really important for us as staff
because it gives us the flexibility to
kind of
take into account in consideration the
future travel plans that
the future community is going to have
yes there's a lot of assumptions there
that we don't currently have and yes
we'll have to do some more strategizing
and planning
but if we don't have that base in place
where we've actually
got ourselves an asset that we can
utilise and do something with
then we can't react fully to the
community's needs and kind of go in the
direction that we would need to go with
community facilities for that area
whether that includes a pool or
just community meeting space we know
that wooden community centre
is really well utilized and that doesn't
have the capacity or the land
to really kind of support any future
expansion
if we were going to do anything further
with the land that we had in that area
there would be an opportunity cost there
would be some form of displacement
for some groups so for staff
and through the the study that we had
done as well
the most logical way forward for us in
our professional opinion is to look at
some land banking to give us the maximum
flexibility to deliver the services that
we know
those people are going to need and to
also take into consideration the
pressures on our current infrastructure
with an additional 10
000 people there and what those travel
patterns might look like as well
so look with that i'm happy to take the
report as read and
hear any feedback or questions thank you
just around
um the uh timing of the community centre
and pegasus you're recommending 22.23
is that a realistic timing to get plans
drawn and
all the other work that would be
required
and what when does this remind me the
expiry on the current lease
with tableton yeah so the expiry of the
current lease would be
um it's in july 25 so what we're trying
to do here is actually give ourselves
enough time to
purchase some land because that
negotiation to be fair could take up a
year up to 18 months
um depending on where it is uh the
council and the wooden shift and
community board and the community
um want us to to go in terms of
purchasing that land we've got a pretty
good idea
you're recommending here 22 23 yep is
the timing better at
23 24 just on just testing whether
it takes time to um design the facility
and get it ready as
are we giving ourselves enough time
in the actual budget sheets we've
actually got it identified as
523.24 year and the remainder in the 25
20 24 25 year to reflect exactly what
you're talking about the fact that
in the recommendation that's got there
is a 223
yeah so so that's obviously not
consistent with what we've actually got
in the budget sheets themselves so
could you could you have as i said at
the start could you have a look over the
recommendations because uh
they don't they're not where it needs to
be framed in which to make a decision
um they're actually from the report that
went to council
end of last year they've just been
copied over which should probably have
something like include could you
just have a look at that please yep
and just while staff do that just
just have a breather for that they come
back to us
because it'll be a part of just have a
stretch for a minute how long would you
need
chris just five minutes
five minutes so maybe just a quick stop
for five minutes
we are scheduled to break at 12 45
because that's when lunch will be ready
um